COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS WILL
COME TO ORDER. IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE
STATE CAPITAL TODAY. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WE WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFIED TODAY.
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WOULD
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE EIGHT NINE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO EIGHT SEVEN SIX
ZERO FIVE NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR ARE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE I NEEDED AND YOU'RE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU. AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE.
MAYBE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS NEED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARING. IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENTS OF ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
SIX BILLS ON OUR AGENDA TODAY.
HAND OUT PARMALEE WE WOULD
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AT THE START
I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT A FEW OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE PLANES THAT
ARE DELAYED AND SO THEY'LL BE
ARRIVING- IN A FEW MINUTES- BUT
FOR. THE PURPOSES OF BEGINNING
OUR HEARING PROCESS WILL BEGIN
AS A COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE
AND- HOPE THAT- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE HERE IN THE CAPITAL
CAN JOIN US DOWN. IN THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE SO FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN- WELCOME TO THE HEARING.
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL THE
FIRST BILL ON OUR CALENDAR AB
THIRTY SEVEN FILE ITEM ONE. AND
WE WELCOME YOU HERE. LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR TESTIMONY
CORRECT THANK YOU- CHAIR GLAZER.
ALL AT THE STARBUCKS IN THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS OUTLINING
COMMON NUMBER THREE OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ARE YOU CITY
THIRTY SEVEN RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT
THE USER- I'D LIKE TO THINK
THAT SHARING COMMITTEE STAFF TO
WORK WITH MY STAFF ON THIS BILL
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
TOGETHER. TO ADDRESS ANY
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD. THANK BY
VOTERS AND POLL WORKERS LAST
YEAR I AUTHORED AB EIGHT SIXTY
WHICH WAS A SUCCESSFUL
BIPARTISAN EFFORT TO SEND EVERY
ACTIVE REGISTERED VOTER A
BALLOT IN THE MAIL. AMONG OTHER
PROVISIONS. ACCORDING TO THE
SECRETARY STATE OVER EIGHTY SIX
POINT 5% OF THE SEVENTEEN AND A
HALF MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
PARTICIPATED IN THE NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY L. AT THE GENERAL
ELECTION. VOTED ON THE BALLOT
THAT WAS MAILED TO THE SHOWS
THAT SENDING EVERYONE A BALLOT
IN THE MAIL PROVIDES VOTERS
ACCESS WHEN VOTERS GET BALLOTS
IN THE MAIL THEY VOTE. SB
THIRTY SEVEN WILL MAKE SOME OF
THESE IMPROVEMENTS PERMANENT
ENSURING THAT EVERY ACTIVE
REGISTERED VOTERS MAILED A
BALLOT FOR EVERY ELECTION.
SIMILAR TO PROVISIONS IN MY
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY LAST YEAR SB
THIRTY SEVEN MAKES A NUMBER OF
OTHER IMPORTANT ACCOMMODATIONS.
HELP FACILITATE VOTING BY MAIL
IN FUTURE ELECTIONS. IT ALLOWS
COUNTIES TO BEGIN PROCESSING A
RETURN TO VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS
EARLIER. SO THAT THEY CAN
BETTER MANAGE THEIR WORKLOAD TO
GET MORE BALLOTS COUNTED ON
ELECTION NIGHT. EXTENDS THE
DEADLINE FOR RECEIPT OF VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT SO THAT VOTERS ARE
NOT DISENFRANCHISED. BY
POTENTIAL POSTAL SERVICE
DELAYS. THAT DIFFERENTLY THIS
BILL SETS MINIMUM VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT DROP OFF LOCATION
REQUIREMENTS. ALONG VOTERS TO
CONVENIENTLY RETURN THEIR
BALLOT. SB THIRTY SEVEN ALSO
ENSURES VOTERS CONTRACT OR
BALLOTS AS THEY MOVE THROUGH
THE MAIL SYSTEM. AND A PROCESS
BY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS. THANK
YOU FOR OUR CONSIDERATION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE- AND TESTIFYING TODAY ARE
CHRISTOPHE MAIRE. OF ABSENTEE
CALIFORNIA AND REAR GILBERT
CALPERS STUDENTS. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN BEFORE
WE I HEAR FROM YOUR WITNESS IS
I THINK WE HAVE A QUORUM HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE I'M GONNA ASK.
OUR CONSULTANT TO A TO CALL THE
ROLL. THANK YOU AS A REMINDER
MEMBERS PLEASE REMEMBER TO TURN
ON AND SPEAK INTO THE
MICROPHONE GLAZER. HERE GLAZER
HERE NIELSEN. NIELSEN HERE
HERTZBERG. LEYVA NEWMAN HERE%
HUMAN HERE OKAY SO WE HAVE A
QUORUM. I WILL LOOK FORWARD NOW
TO HEARING FROM THE- WITNESSES
IN FAVOR I WANT TO REMIND THEM
AND OTHERS WHO WILL TESTIFIED
TODAY THAT. WE'RE GOING TO
ESTABLISH A- TIME LIMIT FOR
WITNESSES TO MINUTES- EACH TWO
MINUTES EACH LIKE TO ENCOURAGE
MEMBERS TO- THOSE TESTIFYING TO
MEET. THAT TIME DEADLINE AFTER
WE HEAR FROM WITNESSES IN FAVOR
AND AGAINST. AS LEAD WITNESSES
WILL HEAR TESTIMONY FROM THOSE
WHO WANT TO PUT THEIR NAME IN A
ASSOCIATION- INTO THE RECORD
AND WE'LL INVITE THEM TO DO
THAT AT THAT TIME. SO FIRST LET
ME INVITE- CHRISTOPH MAIER THE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR ASKING
CALIFORNIA TO- PREPARE AND
PRESENT HIS TESTIMONY. WELCOME
THANK YOU MORNING CHAIR NUMBERS
WE HAD ASKED ME STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
SEVEN WHICH CONTINUES
CALIFORNIA'S PUSH TOWARD MORE
ACCEPTABLE ELECTIONS FOR ALL
OUR STATE STANDS IN STARK
CONTRAST WITH OTHER STATES IN
THE COUNTRY THAT CURRENTLY SEEK
TO MAKE VOTING MORE DIFFICULT.
WHAT'S THAT PLACE RESTRICTIONS
ON VOTING DISPROPORTIONATELY
AND OFTEN INTENTIONALLY
DISENFRANCHISED PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND LOWER INCOME INDIVIDUALS.
LAWS SUCH AS AB THIRTY SEVEN ON
THE OTHER HAND ALLOW FOR
FLEXIBILITY IN THE VOTING
PROCESS AND ELIMINATE THE
SCHEDULING CONFLICTS. WHICH
CONTINUE TO BE A BARRIER FOR
VOTING FOR MANY. THIS MEASURE
WILL RESULT IN AN ADDITION IN
AN ADDITIONAL TWO POINT THREE
MILLION BALLOTS BEING SENT TO
VOTERS WHO MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
VOTE OTHERWISE. A RELIABLE
TRACKING SYSTEM WILL PROVIDE
VOTERS WITH CLARITY AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MANY BALLOTS.
THAT ARE FLAGGED AS IMPROPER.
STUDIES FROM THE PAST DECADE BY
ARIZONA STATE UNIVERSITY
DARTMOUTH BRIGHAM YOUNG
UNIVERSITY THE REPUBLICAN
NATIONAL LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
AND MANY OTHERS HAVE ALL FOUND
THAT VOTING FRAUD IS INCREDIBLY
RARE AND ISOLATED. FOR ALL
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I
WANT TO INVITE RIA GILBERT-
WHO'S THE CHAIR OF CALPERS
STUDENTS TO I JOIN US I THINK
ON OUR PHONE LINES.
UNDISCOVERED ARE YOU THERE YET
PLEASE PROVIDE GOING UNTESTED
MORNINGTON. HI MY NAME IS
RECALL YELL AND I NEEDS BOARD
CHAIR FOR. STUDENT A STUDENT
RUN NONPROFIT THAT WORKS TO
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT MAKE
COLLEGE MORE AFFORDABLE AND
HELP YOUNG PEOPLE TURN OUT TO
VOTE. YOUNG PEOPLE ARE THE
LARGEST BLOCK OF POTENTIAL
VOTERS IN THE COUNTRY WITH OUR
OWN VALUES AND IDEAS. THE
PROPERTY MARKET YOU TO WORK
YOUNG PEOPLE NEED TO
PARTICIPATE. LOCALLY IS BETTER
TURNOUT IS ON THE RISE IN
TWENTY TWENTY YEARS BURGER
TURNOUT AND CALIFORNIA
INCREASED BY SEVENTEEN
PERCENTAGE POINTS FROM THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN ELECTION ONE OF
THE BIGGEST INCREASES OF ANY
STATE. CALIFORNIA'S DECISION TO
SEND EVERY VOTER A VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT WOULD LIKELY A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE INCREASE IN
TURNOUT AND OTHER STATES
IMPLEMENTED BOTH BY MAIL
PROGRAMS ALSO SAW THE LARGEST
INCREASE IN YOUTH VOTER
TURNOUT. WITH THIS BILL I'M
CERTAIN WE'LL SEE MORE YOUNG
PEOPLE TURN OUT TO GO AND
PARTICIPATE IN OUR DEMOCRACY.
YOU DON'T HAVE A PARTICULARLY
DIFFICULT TIME GETTING TO THE
POLLS AS THEY OFTEN HAVE
MULTIPLE OBLIGATIONS SUCH AS
CLASSES ARE WORK THEY CANNOT
GET OUT OF. MANY BLACK
TRANSPORTATION AND ARE ALSO
DETERMINED BY THE LONG LINES
THAT YOU NEED TO WAIT ABOUT TWO
HOURS TO CAST THEIR VOTE. WE
SAW JUST HOW MANY YOUNG PEOPLE
WERE ABLE TO VOTE THIS YEAR. IN
CALIFORNIA TO THE CONTINUATION
OF THE- NOW AND WE CAN TO.
FOSTERING THE CAN GAUGE AND THE
YOUNG. AT THROUGH THE- SENDING
EVERY VOTER A BILL BY MAIL. IN
THE REMINDER BOW AND CONVENE
OPTION FOR PEOPLE MIGHT HAVE
TRACKED THE CAR TO READY TO
VOTE BY MAIL. BUT DESPITE THAT
IS THE CAN BE OPTION FOR THEM
WHEN ELECTION COMES. WE SHOULD
BE OFFERING THIS OP TO PURCHASE.
IN DEMOCRATS PROCESS THAT EVERY
ELECTION. I ENCOURAGE. WITH TO
VOTE YES EIGHTY THIRTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. RIFIC THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE NOT
GOING FROM OTHER WITNESSES
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. WILL
BEGIN HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE IS A ONE
HERE WISHES TO SPEAK IN. FAVOR
GOING TO GO TO A REMOTE HEARING
ROOM. SCENE AND NO ONE THERE
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE MODERATOR
FONG MODERATOR ASK. MODERATOR
IF YOU ASK ANYONE WHO'D LIKE
TO. PUT THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION INTO THE RECORD IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TO PLEASE
SO INDICATE SO WE CAN HEAR FROM
THEM NOW. IF YOU LIKE TO QUEUE
UP N SUPPORT OF THIS BILL YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ANALYSTS LIKE WE HAVE
ABOUT SEVEN OR EIGHT IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME WILL BEGIN WITH
LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN THIS IS TONY TO
KERO REPRESENTING THE
IN
THANK YOU. MODERATOR NOT ONLY A
LITTLE LINE NUMBER NINETEEN
THAT'S ONE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING SURE NUMBERS
PERSECUTE US ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AT
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BORDERLINE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE THAT'S TWO
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING DONNA THANKS FOR
PRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NUMBER
LINE NUMBER TWENTY THAT'S TWO
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
GOOD MORNING THIS IS LUCY
SALCEDO CARTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LEVEL ONE NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR TO FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING BUT PACKAGING
DOLLARS NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SUCH WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THE LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE TWO FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
DOOR ROSA THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA WELL WE
SUPPORT- UNIVERSAL MAILING OF
BALLOTS AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE WORK THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS DONE TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS THAT. ENCOURAGED
VOTING ACCESS. ALL DO STILL
RETAIN THE SUPPORT OF AMENDED
PETITION BECAUSE WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS REQUIRED
VOTER EDUCATION. AND THAT ALL
VOTERS KNOW EXACTLY HOW TO USE
THOSE OPEN MAIL ABOUT SELL THE
RECEIVING- AND ALSO THAT THEY
KNOW THAT THEY'RE THEY HAVE
OPTIONS TO VOTE IN PERSON.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE HAVE YOUR FOR. YOUR
LETTER IN THE RECORD HERE AS
WELL. MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. OVERLIE NUMBER TWENTY
THREE TO THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. STEPHANIE ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE PHONE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT TERRIFIC
WE'RE GOING TO NOW GO TO THOSE
WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTY SEVEN I DON'T HAVE ANY
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
NOTED BUT WILL BEGIN HERE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHICH
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION AB THIRTY
SEVEN. ALL RIGHT SEEN ON WILL
GO TO OUR REMOTE. HEARING SPACE
SCENE NO ONE THERE WILL GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES. MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD ASK ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB
THIRTY SEVEN TO PLEASE SO
INDICATE SO WE CAN HEAR THEIR
TESTIMONY NOW. YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB THREE
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN IF
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO
HAVE ONE IN OPPOSITION WE WILL
GO TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY SIX
TWO SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
STILL DON'T SEEM TO BE GETTING
LIKE REPRESENTATION WHY DON'T
YOU HAE A LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION THAT SEEMS LIKE A
REALLY IMPORTANT MATTER WAS A
HOLIDAY. ANYTHING FURTHER MA'AM
NOT A MODERATOR WOULD YOU GO TO
THE NEXT WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE. AND THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIR
LAST FOR ONE LAST FINAL CALL
FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION AB THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE INDICATE. PODERIA
ANYBODY FURTHER MATTERS BUT NO
ONE ELSE QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU AGAIN FOR ALL
YOUR GOOD WORK ON OUR BEHALF
TODAY. WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSIONS AND COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ANY MEMBER. COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. SENATOR NEWMAN. I
WILL BE BRAVE AT BY SENTIMENT
BERMAN GOOD TO SEE YOU GLAD TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY WHEN
IT'S APPROPRIATE- GLAD TO MOVE
THE BILL AND I WOULD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK INCLUDES A CO
AUTHOR AT SUCH TIME IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN. THE OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER- ONE
ISSUE THAT HAS COME UP IN SOME
OF THE CORRESPONDENCE IS THE
ISSUE OF MAYBE PEOPLE OF THE
OVERSEAS BALLOTS- THAT MIGHT
PUT THEM IN THE MAIL- BEFORE
ELECTION DAY BUT- JUST BY THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT MAY NOT GET
IN TIME I AS I UNDERSTAND YOUR
BILL A LIMITS THE COUNTING TO
SEVEN DAYS AFTER THE ELECTION
AS POST MARKET TO ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE YEAH SO- EXISTING LAW
PRIOR TO TWENTY TWENTY WAS
THREE DAYS- IN TWENTY TWENTY WE
EXTENDED IT TO SEVENTEEN DAYS
BECAUSE WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT-
COVERT RELATED DELAYS TO THE
MAIL SERVICE- BUT THAT WAS
NEVER MEANT TO. BE THE
PERMANENT- EXTENSION SO IN IN
THIS BILL WE CHOSE SEVEN DAYS
THAT CAME OUT OF DATA FROM THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND
DISCUSSIONS WITH COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS TO TRY TO
FIND A SWEET SPOT TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU KNOW NOBODY WHO WHO.
TRIES TO VOTE AND DOES VOTE
LEGALLY- HAS THE ROAD DISCARDED
BUT THAT LSO WE GIVE THE
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS TIME TO THE
YOU KNOW PROCESS THE BALLOT
THAT THEY RECEIVE AND CERTIFY
THE ELECTION AND THEN DO YOU
THINK AND I THINK THERE MIGHT
BE SOME REFERENCE OF THIS MAN
ALICE'S. WHAT WOULD YOU THINK
THAT CAPTURES IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBER OF FOLKS I MEAN HOW MANY
PEOPLE DO YOU THINK WOULD GET
EXCLUDED FROM CIRCUIT BUT YOU
KNOW BAD CIRCUMSTANCE OR MAYBE
EVEN AGAIN A BALLOT FROM
OVERSEAS THAT TAKES A LOT
LONGER TO GET HERE IF YOU HAVE
ANY SENSE OF. UNDER THE SEVEN
DAY HOW MANY WOULD MIGHT BE
EXCLUDED I NORMAL I DON'T- BUT
I CAN I CAN GET BACK TO YOU- ON
THAT OUR OLD CHECK THE ANALYSIS
ALSO TO SEE IF THERE'S BETTER
DATA AND THERE MY GOAL IS THAT
NOBODY GETS EXCLUDED- SO- HAPPY
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD AND CAN HAVE
THEM BE A PART OF OUR
CONVERSATION TERRIFIC I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT I. I AM NOT
HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY I THINK THIS EFFORT TO
MAIL BALLOTS TO VOTERS IS AN
INCREDIBLE PROGRESSIVE OUTREACH
SAID IT THAT MAKES CALIFORNIA
SHINE REALLY IN THE COUNTRY FOR
OUR BELIEF THAT VOTING MATTERS
WE WANT TO MAKE IT IS EASY- AND
HONEST AS POSSIBLE. AND I THINK
THAT YOU'VE REALLY TAKEN THE
LEAD IN THIS AREA I. OF YOUR
LEADER. IN I THINK THIS BILL
REFLECTS. REALLY GOOD STRONG.
PUBLIC POLICY ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCES THAT WE HAVE HAD
RELIED UPON THOSE. SEEN HOW
TURNOUT HAS GONE OUT. AND IT'S
ALL POINTED IN A VERY POSITIVE
DIRECTION AS REFLECTED IN YOUR
BILL TO HAPPY TO SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU I RECOGNIZE EMOTIONS.
FROM SENATOR NEWMAN LAW TO GIVE
YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE HI
I COULDN'T. SAY IT DO IT BETTER
THAN YOU JUST DID- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED IS
THAT CORRECT. TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AND IF THE
CONSULTANT WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
AB THIRTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
pCOMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG. LEYVA
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN HI. ALL
RIGHT SO THAT THE BILL IS GOING
TO BE PUT ON CALL AS WE WAIT
FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN FOR THAT AND YOU AT THE
ITEM NUMBER TWO ON OUR AGENDA
AS WELL. A. B. SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE. AND YOU ARE WELCOME TO
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS
PERSONAL LIKE THE START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED. TECHNICAL MOMENT
THAT IS FOUND IN COMMON NUMBER
TWO ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. I WANT TO
THANK YOU AGAIN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL. AND FOR
IDENTIFYING THE TECHNICAL
ISSUE. IN APRIL THE NEW YORK
TIMES RELEASED AN INVESTIGATION
INTO THE PRACTICE OF POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS. USING PRE CHECKED
BOXES THAT AUTHORIZED RECURRING
DONATIONS WHEN A PERSON. MAKES
A CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION ONLINE.
IN PARTICULAR THE REPORT FOUND
THAT FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP'S REELECTION CAMPAIGN.
MADE EXTENSIVE USE OF THESE PRE
CHECKED BOXES. AS THE CAMPAIGN
RAN LOW ON MONEY ITS TACTICS
BECAME INCREASINGLY DECEPTIVE
AND IT FIXED UP TO OBSCURE
DISCLOSURES. THAT DONORS WERE
AUTHORIZING RECURRING
CONTRIBUTIONS BY FEELING THE
DESELECT THOSE PRE CHECKED
BOXES. THE CAMPAIGN
ADDITIONALLY CHANGE THE
DONATIONS FROM MONTHLY TO
WEEKLY. HE HAD ADDED A SECOND
PRE CHECK BOX. THAT AUTHORIZED
AN ADDITIONAL CONTRIBUTION TO
BE MADE LATER IN THE MONTH. AS
A RESULT A FAILURE BY A DONOR
TO DESELECT THESE PRE CHECKED
BOXES. COULD RESULT IN THAT
DONOR MAKING AS MANY AS. SIX
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS IN ONE
MONTH. SOME CONTENT SHOULD HAD
THEIR ACCOUNT DRAINED FROZEN.
WHETHER CREDIT CARD MAXED OUT.
OTHER ENDED UP MAKING CAMPAIGN
DONATIONS WELL IN EXCESS OF THE
MAXIMUM ALLOWABLE UNDER FEDERAL
LAW. AS A RESULT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ENDED UP REFUNDING TEN
POINT 7% OF THE MONEY THAT IT
RAISED ONLINE IN TWENTY TWENTY.
A RATE NEARLY FIVE TIMES TAT
OF THE BIDEN CAMPAIGNS REFUND
RATE FOR ONLINE CONTRIBUTIONS.
IN ALL THE NEW YORK TIMES
REPORTED THAT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND AFFILIATED
POLITICAL ORGANIZATIONS. WERE
FORCED TO REFUND OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS. TOTALING MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. IN CALIFORNIA
AT LEAST ONE MAJOR CANDIDATE
FOR GOVERNOR IN THE UPCOMING
RECALL ELECTION CONTINUES TO
USE. THESE PRE CHECKED BOXES TO
AUTHORIZE RECURRING CAMPAIGN
DONATIONS. AND OTHER POLITICAL
COMMITTEES CONTINUE TO SOLICIT
RECURRING DONATIONS FOR
DECEITFUL.PRECHECK
AUTHORIZATION BOXES. EARLIER
THIS MONTH ONE SUCH
SOLICITATION WARRANTED DONORS
THAT ON CHECKING THE
PRESELECTED AUTHORIZATION BOX.
WOULD QUOTE HELP THE LEFT
CANCEL THE FOURTH OF JULY IN
THE RACE. TRUMP I'M GLAD WE ALL
WERE ABLE TO ENJOY YOUR FOURTH
OF JULY. CANDIDATES AND
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO RELY ON THAT KIND OF
DECEPTION AND TRICKERY TO RAISE
MONEY TO FUND THEIR CAMPAIGNS.
THAT'S WHY I'M OFFERING AB AB
SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE WHICH
PROHIBITS CANDIDATES OR
COMMITTEES FROM SOLICITING OR
ACCEPTING. RECURRING CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS WITHOUT RECEIVING
THE CONTRIBUTORS AFFIRMATIVE
CONSENT. SB SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
FURTHER MAKES IT CLEAR THAT A
PRE CHECK BOX. AUTHORIZING A
RECURRING CONTRIBUTION DOES NOT
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT. CAMPAIGNS
WOULD STILL BE ABLE TO ASK
CONTRIBUTORS TO SIGN UP TO MAKE
RECURRING DONATIONS. BUT THE
CONTRIBUTORS WOULD HAVE TO TAKE
AFFIRMATIVE STEPS. TO ENROLL
THEMSELVES IN RECURRING
CONTRIBUTIONS. SB SEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE ADDITIONALLY REQUIRES A
CANDIDATE OR COMMITTEE THAT
ACCEPTS A RECURRING
CONTRIBUTIONS. TO PROVIDE A
RECEIPT FOR EACH CONTRIBUTION.
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
NECESSARY TO CANCEL THE
RECURRING CONTRIBUTION. INTO
IMMEDIATELY CANCEL A RECURRING
CONTRIBUTION UPON REQUEST. I
HOPE YOU WILL JOIN ME IN
WORKING TO AT A PRACTICE THAT
DAN SCHNUR. A FORMER CHAIR OF
THE FEDERAL AND THE FAIRPORT A
PRACTICES COMMISSION. CALLED
THE QUOTE AND- RIGHT. PRACTICE
THAT TAKES ADVANTAGE OF
INNOCENT PEOPLE AND QUOTE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AS I UNDERSTAND IT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY LEAD THAT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THAT WE
HAVE SOMEONE AVAILABLE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS- BUT LET'S
GO TO HERE IN THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. C. NINE WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO A REMOTE HEARING
SPACE. AND SEE NONE THERE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR
WOULD YOU ASK THOSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE TO. PLEASE
SO INDICATE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. MISTER CHAIR
WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE SHOWING
UP IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
VERY GOOD WILL NOT GO TO THOSE
WHO WILL FLAT LINE AT FLIGHT
WANTED. IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WILL FIRST
BEGAN IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. C. NINE HERE WILL GO TO
OUR REMOTE HEARING SPACE. THE
NINE THERE WILL GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES MODERATE WOULD YOU ASK
THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE TO PLEASE SO INDICATE. IF
YOU WISH TO INDICATE OPPOSITION
TO AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER TAYLOR IS KNOWN
QUEUING UP IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME OKAY- WE'RE GOING TO
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MEMBERS AND YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ALL
RIGHT ALL SEEN- NINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGAIN I THINK THAT I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THIS SPACE. YOU KNOW WE TRY TO
MAKE LAWS INTO TRYING TO HOPE
THAT PEOPLE FOLLOW THEM AND NOT
TRY TO GET AROUND THEM AND-
ONCE AGAIN WE SAW THE PROBLEMS
THAT USE YOU INDICATED IN YOUR
TESTIMONY AND I THINK THIS IS
A- AN IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION MEASURE. I'M GLAD
THAT YOU FELT WORKED ON IT AND
BROUGHT THIS BILL BEFORE US
NOTHING FURTHER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU- CHAIR AND
YEAH I APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE IN THAT WE'RE GOING
TO GATHER. TO MAKE. CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS LESS DECEPTIVE
AND MORE TRANSPARENCY IN THAT
SPACE AND RESPECT OUR THROAT.
DURATEC MOVE THE BILL SENATOR
NEWMAN HAS MOVED THE BILL THIS
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS IS THAT CORRECT
CONSULT CORRECT. OKAY AND YOU
CAN CALL THE ROLL. AB SEVEN
SEVEN. MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE
HERTZBERG. LEYVA NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT NEWMAN I. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA PUT THAT BILL ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER DID YOU
GET IT. ALL RIGHT SEEING THAT-
OUR NEXT- AGENDA ITEM THE
AUTHOR IS NOT PRESENT WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO. AGENDA ITEM FOR
AV FOR TWENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES. SIR
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE WITH
FORTY YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR. AND SENATORS
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
ASIDE BEFORE YOU TODAY ON. AB
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT. AB FOUR
TWENTY IT IS RATHER SIMPLE AND
STRIKES AT THE CORE OF OUR
DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS. WE
MUST ENSURE THAT OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE STRUCTURED A
WITH AT LEAST THE BEST ELECTED
REPRESENTATION POSSIBLE. THIS
BILL GUARANTEES ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR COUNTY SUPERVISOR BY
ALLOWING THEM TO STAND FOR RE
ELECTION GAIN EXPERTISE TO THE
JOB FOR A MINIMUM OF TWO
ELECTED TERMS IN OFFICE. WILL
ALSO CONTINUE TO ALLOW THEM
ADEQUATE COMPENSATION AS LAID
OUT IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. TO HAVE QUALIFIED
CANDIDATES FROM ALL WALKS OF
LIFE THAT ARE NOT JUST
INDEPENDENTLY WEALTHY. AB
TWENTY DOES NOT CONTAIN A
RETROACTIVE CLAUSE IT WILL NOT
DIRECTLY OVERTURN. ANY LOCAL
MEASURES WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
THAT. ADDITIONALLY BUT WORKING
WITH THE CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE
I'M ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD FURTHER
CLARIFY. THAT THIS MEASURE IS
PROSPECTIVE IN NATURE. HOWEVER
THERE WAS A RECENT LOCAL
MEASURE THAT HIGHLIGHTED
DEFICIENCY IN STATE LAW. THAT
WE MUST ADDRESS RESULTING IN
THIS BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY. I
AM JOINED TODAY BY A JEAN HURST
ON BEHALF THE URBAN COUNTIES
CALIFORNIA'S WELL AS RC RC
TODAY. I'M ALSO JOINED BY TERRY
BRENNAN ON BEHALF OF S. C. A.
USED. NOT THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SO WE'LL GO TO YOUR LEAD
WITNESSES ALL BEGIN WITH TERRY
BRENNAN. DIRECTOR OF PENSIONS
REVENUE AND BUDGETS WITH SEIU.
THE READING WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE WITH THE QUARTIER
TESTIMONY. IF PARENTS SENATORS
JERRY BROWN AND BEHALF BEST
YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA- ANYBODY
WHO'S FOLLOWED- FEI USE
ACTIVITIES STUDENT. ALEXION'S
NOW WE'VE BEEN ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE DEBATE ABOUT TERM LIMITS.
MOSTLY OPPOSING THEM INTO STATE
LEVEL SOMETIMES SUPPORTING THAT
THE LOCAL. BUT HE KNOWS THAT WE
EVER BEEN- SUPPORTIVE OF SINGLE
CURRENT TERM LIMITS- IT'S THE
EVIDENCE IS OUT THERE IT'S NOT
EFFECTIVE- IT DOES NOT HELP
THE- DEMOCRATIC PROCESS. AHA
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULDN'T BE
SPREAD OUT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THAT A MINIMUM OF TWO
TERM LIMITS HIS IS A REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION. AND DIRECTION
FOR THIS LEGISLATURE TO GIVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR THAT
REASON. WE ARE PERJURE I
SUPPORT THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER BRANDON. SO I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE JEAN HURST
WHO'S THE LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
WITH THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA. ON THE PHONE LINES.
MODERATOR WOULD YOU INVITE. A
MISS HEARST TO. PRESENTER
TESTIMONY NOW. THANK YOU MR
CAROLINE. YES YOU CAN YEAH.
THANK YOU AND JANE HARMON
CALLING IN TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEANS EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
WHICH WOULD ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA COUNTY MORE THAN
PEOPLE RIGHT THERE THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO A TERM LIMIT WHETHER
BRADY HARDER OR GREAT WOMEN.
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR A MINIMUM AND
YOU TURN I DON'T THINK THEY
WERE QUITE EXISTING LAW THAT
THE BOARD OF PEOPLE READ ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PRESCRIBING
COMPENSATION FOR ALL COUNTY.
OFFICERS INCLUDING THE MORE
THAN. ARE WE TRYING SUPPORT THE
CHANGES ACTUALLY DOING AND-
LEVEL OF COMMAND TO THE ON
COUNTY. RIGHT A LOT OF
EXPERTISE AND TRYING TO THE OFF.
AND EVERYONE WHO ANY OF. HELLO
CAN BECOME AND. HELLO AND THE
NO ONE FINAL IN MIDDLE PREVENT
OR- FOR BROAD. OF FEDERAL DATA
LOCAL. THAT CAN BE. EVIDENCE
OVER THE YEAR TRYING AT THE
LOCAL FRIENDLY RESPONSE IN
DOWNING. I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THE NEED FOR HIGH FOR WRITER
GAIN EXPERIENCE IN THE OUR- SET
TO RECALL NATION FINANCIAL RISK.
I THINK OF HER SIMPLY DOES
ALLOW FOR THE TO OF PROJECT.
AND OTHER IS OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT A SINGLE
LIMITS WOULD MEAN FOR HOLDEN
MAKING AND THURMOND. THAT THE
LOCAL. RARELY RELIABILITY
THEORIES AND ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT REQUIRE. TO GET BRADFORD
HE UNDER THE OF THE WAY ARRAY
OF THE OF ALL AT THE RESULT
REQUIRE- YOUR KNOW AB. TWENTY
THE OPERATOR WOULD YOU ASK
THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
FAVOR OF AB FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
TO PLEASE SO INDICATE. AND
REMIND. YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE.
JUST REMINDING THEM THAT THAT
THIS PART OF THE TO AND THE
HEARING WILL JUST GIVE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION. OF SUPPORT. GO
AHEAD OPERATOR. THANK YOU
MISTER SHE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
VOICE. FOR BI FOR TO. EIGHT
PLEASED ONE AND THEN ZERO THIS
TIME. WE HAVE ONE QUEUING UP-
PLEASE ALLOW A MOMENT FOR US TO
PROVIDE THE NO ONE EVER. WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY THAT'S
THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN- I
WAS DISCONNECTED I WAS TRYING
TO OPPOSE AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
THE TRASHING DONALD TRUMP BILL.
A BILL THAT I KNOW THE HEARING
HEALTHCARE RECORD THAT THAT
BILL THE HEARING ON THAT
BELIEVE ME OFF. HERE ON THAT
BEEN CUT ME OFF AND CUT ME OFF
IF YOU DO THAT OFTEN OKAY YOU
KNOW THE RECORD PLEASE HAPPY
TO. SO NOTED OPERATOR NEXT.
CALL I WOULD APPRECIATE IT THE-
YEAH. CAN WE DO HAVE ANOTHER
ONE IN Q. WILL GO TO A NUMBER
TWO NINE TO NINE YOUR LIFE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING- MY NAME IS
PAUL FOREVER BEHALF OF THE
ILLEGALITY. FILTERS AND TO
CALIFORNIA'S IN THE- CAN YOU
GIVE ME THAT THIS REALTORS IN
CORONA. AND THE CALIFORNIA BOTH
THE REALTOR. IN ALL DESERT-
WOULD LIKE IT'S BUT SUPPORT FOR
A BI FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR.
COULD NOT COLOR PLAY. MISTER
CHAIR HAVE EXAM THE QUEUE THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GOING
TO NOW GO TO THOSE WHO WANT TO.
TEST IN OPPOSITION. TO AB FOR
TWENTY EIGHT AS I UNDERSTAND IT
TOM MURPHY PRESIDENT OF THE
READ BRANDON GROUP- IS ON THE
PHONE LINES UP. MISTER MURPHY
IF YOU'RE THERE YOU'RE WELCOME
TO BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY NOW.
GOOD MORNING- THANKS FOR
PROVIDING THE PPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK- THE EARLIER DISCUSSION
FOR A D. THIRTY SEVEN ABOUT
DISENFRANCHISES WAS INTERESTING
AND HIGHLY BECAUSE THE
DEFINITION OF DISENFRANCHISES.
LOU CALLS FROM ONE OF THEIR
RIGHTS AND- FOR THE FREEDOM
HABITANT OF THE BRUCE OF BEER
COUNTY. IN ORDER EIGHT PROPOSAL
BY POLITICAL SENT TO DO EXACTLY
THAT. ONE QUESTION THE
COMMITTEE DOES HAVE TODAY. THE
BILL- THAT PLACES POLICE. ON
THE RIGHTS HOST. UNFORTUNATELY
THE- IT THE FOR ACTORS OF THE
RIGHT TO A NEW. CURRENTLY
VOTERS YOU'LL PLEASE SET YOUR
MOMENTS OF THEY DEEM
APPROPRIATE APPROVAL OF A CHORD
THE- WILL LIMIT THE FREEDOM FOR
EVERY. IN THE STATE. HERE IS
HOW. HELLO THE TO APPROVE AB.
TWENTY EIGHT. COMPELLING DOES
NOT EXIST WHATEVER. FOR TWENTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY HAD TEN BUT WITH
POLITICAL STEP IN THE CAMPUS
YOU KNOW OVERTURNED NAY K. THE
DELIVERY BUT MORE THAN THIRDS
OF ABOUT IN THE COUNTY DESPITE
THE OTHERS BECAUSE THE CONS.
BUT ONE OF THE TOWARD EIGHT IS
TO DEFEND. THE VOTERS OF ALL
BUT ONE MILLION IN FAIRBURN CAN.
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THIS
PASSED. WHY BOTHER VOTING. IF
THE WEATHER MANEUVER THE VOTE I
WOULD WANT MILLION P. CAN
ORDERED. NO THE ONLY APPROACH
IMPROPER VOTER FUNDED POINT
TWENTY EIGHT. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER MOORE I
DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER LEAD OPPA
WITH. WILL FIRST GO TO ROOM
THIRTY ONE ONE WE'RE WHERE ARE
HEARING IS TAKING ANYONE WANTS
TO SPEAK AT OFFICE. THE NINE GO
TO OUR REMOTE HERE. ROOM SEE
WITNESSES THERE WILL GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES MODERATOR WOULD YOU
QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB FOR TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND MR CHERRY DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY IN Q. FOUR OPPOSITION
TO AB FOR TWENTY. OKAY VERY
GOOD WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS MEMBERS CENTER
LEYVA. YOU MISTER CARE GOOD
MORNING AND GOOD MORNING TO THE
AUTHOR WE ARE ON THE BOTH ON
THE SAME VERY DELAYED FLIGHT
YES MORNING GLAD THAT WE BOTH
MADE IT HERE SAFE AND SOUND- I
CANNOT SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
WHICH YOU ALREADY KNOW. I FEEL
VERY UNCOMFORTABLE-
REPRESENTING TEN OF MY ELEVEN
CITIES THAT ARE IN SAN MARINO
COUNTY I WAS NOT SUPPORTIVE OF
MEASURE K. MEASURE TO PAY CAP
K. PASSED OVERWHELMINGLY. I
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL DOESN'T
SPECIFICALLY SPEAK TO MAKE SURE
K. BUT TO ME IT LOOKS LIKE A
WORKAROUND IT LOOKS LIKE THE
VOTERS VOTED WE DIDN'T LIKE IT
SO IN SACRAMENTO WE'RE GONNA
TELL THEM WHAT THEY SHOULD DO.
IT ALSO MAKES YOU FEEL A LITTLE
BIT OF LIKE WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
GEORGIA- PEOPLE DIDN'T LIKE
WHAT HAPPENED IN GEORGIA THE
OUTCOME OF THE VOTE SO NOW
PEOPLE IN POWER ARE TRYING TO
CHANGE. THE WAY PEOPLE VOTE TO
GET THE OUTCOME THAT THEY WANT.
I DO BELIEVE THAT A ONE TERM
TERM LIMIT IS TERRIBLE AND IT
WILL NOT ALLOW PEOPLE TO GET
THE EXPERTISE. BUT IT I ALSO
JUST FEEL THAT THIS IS A WORK
AROUND PEOPLE VOTED ON MEASURE
K. AN OVERWHELMINGLY AND I
THINK THAT IT LOOKS LIKE WE IN
SACRAMENTO TRYING TO TELL THEM
WHAT TO DO. SO NONE OF THIS IS
NEWS TO THE AUTHOR I HAVE TOLD
HIM THIS I WILL BE VOTING NO
TODAY. THE CENTER LEYVA ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTION
MISTER CHAIR IF I CAN JUST TALK
ABOUT THE EXCITED I WANT TO
MANDATE TO GIVE YOU A CHANCE
DAHLE GRAHAM AND THEY JUST AS
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES. A C. NINE
WOULD YOU YOU'RE WELCOME TO IT.
SHARE YOUR- SURE I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE- THAT IT IS A BY.
OF CLEAR IN REGARDS TO- THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER THIS IS A
WORKAROUND OR TO CHANGE AFTER.
THE FACT- IN FACT THAT WAS A
CONVERSATION THE CHAIR AND I-
HAD HAD SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE IT
WAS OUR INTENT GOING TO THE
ASSEMBLY. THAT THIS WAS ONLY
PERSPECTIVE- AND WORKING WITH
THE CHAIR AND WITH THE
COMMITTEE WE ACTUALLY PUT THAT
LANGUAGE AND- SO THAT IT IS.
ABSOLUTELY ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
THAT THIS DOES NOT. A DAY THAT
HAS. WHAT HAPPENED SAN BENITO
COUNTY. AND IS NOT AFFECTED
THIS IS ONLY GOING FORWARD I
JUST WANT TO READ THE LANGUAGE
THAT'S HERE IT SAYS. ANY
PROPOSAL TO LIMIT THE NUMBER OF
TERMS A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS MAY SERVE ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. SHOPWISE
PROSPECTIVELY ONLY. AND SHALL
NOT BECOME OPERATIVE UNLESS IT
IS SUBMITTED TO THE LECTURES OF
THE COUNTY AND A REGULAR
SCHEDULE ACTION. AND A MAJORITY
OF THE VOTES CAST ON THE
QUESTION FAVOR THE ADOPTION OF
THE PROPOSAL. AND IT SAYS THE
CHANGES MADE TO THE SUBDIVISION
BY THE ACTOR ADDED THIS
PARAGRAPH SHALL NOT AFFECT ANY
TERM LIMITS. THEY WERE LEGALLY
IN EFFECT PRIOR TO JANUARY ONE.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO IT'S
ABSOLUTELY. ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
THAT THIS GOES INTO EFFECT
AFTER JANUARY ONE AND ANYTHING
THAT WAS THAT WAS LEGALLY THEIR
APPS BEFORE- REMAINS. AND IT
REMAINS IN EFFECT. VERY GOOD.
LEYVA IT I WOULD SAY I DO KNOW
THAT I DO KNOW THE LANGUAGE BUT
WHAT WE DO UP HERE SOMETIMES
CAN BE NUANCED. AND WHAT PEOPLE
THINK WE DID AND WHAT WE
ACTUALLY DID- IT'S THEIR
PERCEPTION IS OUR REALITY. AND
I THINK THAT MOST PEOPLE WILL
NOT SEE IT AND KNOW THAT IT'S
PERSPECTIVE. AND IT'S STILL TO
ME LOOKS LIKE A WORKAROUND
SOMETHINGS I AGREE I. READ THE
LANGUAGE I UNDERSTAND BUT I
JUST THINK IT LOOKS BAD FOR ALL
OF US. THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THANK YOU- FOR WORKING WITH ME
AND MY STAFF ON THIS BILL. AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
INTENTIONS ARE CLEAR AND THAT
THE PLAIN LANGUAGE THAT IS
BEING PROPOSED. AND I THINK
THAT. A LOT OF THIS BILL ON THE
FACT THAT THE EXISTING-
LIMITATIONS OR- LACK THEREOF IN
IN PLACES LIKE SAN BERNARDINO.
I RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS REALLY
SENDING A MESSAGE TO THE
BROADER COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE. THAT MAY BE
CONSIDERING TERM LIMITS GOING
FORWARD AND- FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES ARE THAT. THAT FOR THE
HUNDREDS OF CITIES. THAT
THEY'RE WELCOME TO DO THAT
THERE'S NO LIMITATION PLACED ON
HERE EXCEPT FOR THE ONE THAT.
SAYS THAT YOU JUST CAN'T
LIMITED LESS THAN TWO TERMS
YEAH THAT TO GIVEN OUR
EXPERIENCE AND- IN HOW WE UP.
HE KNOWS THE CHALLENGES OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. THAT YOU DO
NEED TO HAVE SOME EXPERIENCE TO
BE ABLE TO BE THOUGHTFUL IN
THOSE SPACES SO. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL. TO US AND
FOR WORKING WITH US IN THE
LANGUAGE THE SENATE. AND WE
WELCOME YOUR CLOTHES. I THINK
YOU JUST- WANTED TO MAYBE GIVE
SORT OF. A QUICK STORY- I FIRST
GOT ELECTED TO. A CITY COUNCIL
MY HOMETOWN WHEN I WAS TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OLD STARTED RUNNING
WHEN I WAS TWENTY FOUR- AND- I
REMEMBER BEING SORT OF BRIGHT
EYED- AND VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THE IDEA OF BEING ABLE TO- TO
SERVE- THE COMMUNITY THAT I
GREW UP IN. I GOT ELECTED WHEN
I WAS WHEN I WAS TWENTY FIVE.
AND I REMEMBER THINKING. AT
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD MAYBE
SOME OF YOU CAN RELATE THAT I
HAD ALL THE ANSWERS I HAD IT
ALL. FIGURED OUT. AND ALL I
NEEDED TO DO IS JUST HAVE THAT
OFFICE AND I WAS- I WAS GOING
TO BE ABLE TO. OTHER OF MY- MY
SMALL TOWN. IT BECAME PRETTY
CLEAR TO ME IN MY SMALL TOWN
OF. A TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE A WITH A FIFTY
EMPLOYEES. AND A BUDGET OF
AROUND TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT HAD AN AWFUL LOT TO LEARN.
I READ EVERY SINGLE WORD OF
THAT AGENDA PACKET BEFORE I
WENT TO THE VOTE- AND I CAN
TELL YOU THAT AFTER THREE YEARS
OF ME SERVING ON THAT COUNCIL.
I STILL DIDN'T HAVE IT FIGURED
OUT IN FACT IT PROBABLY TOOK ME
FIVE YEARS TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND. THAT THE DECISION
THAT I WAS MAKING THE LONG TERM
IMPACT OF THOSE OF THOSE
DECISIONS. AND THAT'S FOR A
LITTLE TINY TOWN OF JUST TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH FIFTY
EMPLOYEES AND A BUDGET. OF TEN
MILLION DOLLARS A CONTRACTED
OUT. OF FIRE AND POLICE
SERVICES. IMAGINE A COUNTY. OF
NORTH OF TWO MILLION PEOPLE.
THAT THAT HAS A BUDGET OF FIVE
SIX BILLION DOLLARS
DISCRETIONARY BUDGET OF ALMOST
A BILLION DOLLARS IN AT THE
AVERAGE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT YOU
WOULD SERVE ON THAT BOARD WOULD
BE EITHER ONE AND A HALF YEARS
OR TWO AND A HALF YEARS THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH TIME FOR THOSE
MEMBERS THE BOARD TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE DECISIONS THAT
ARE BEING MADE. THIS IS NOT
ABOUT GOING BACK IN- IN
OVERTURNING THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE FOR THOSE WHO'VE ALREADY
VOTED BUT IT IS MAKING SURE
THAT THAT GOING FORWARD FOR THE
OTHER FIFTY SEVEN COUNTIES I IN
CALIFORNIA WHO- BEAR MIGHT BE
INITIATIVE THAT THERE'D BE TERM
LIMITS TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'VE
GOT SOME SERVICE ON THAT BOARD
SOME EXPERTISE SO THEY CAN EDIT
MAKING DECISIONS SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CLOTHES ASSEMBLY MEMBER I SEE
IT MOTION FROM SENATOR NEWMAN
THAT DO PASS AS AMENDED TO-
APPROPRIATIONS ACT NOW JUST TO
PASS- AT AS AMENDED SO WITH
THAT IF THE CONSOLE WOULD CALL
THE ROLL. AB FOUR TO EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
INTO PASSES MOUNTED GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO
HERTZBERG LEYVA NO RIVER NO
NEWMAN HI NEWMAN I GONNA PUT
THAT DEAL ON CALL FOR OUR
ABSENT NUMBER THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I UNDERSTAND
YOU HAVE A SECOND BILL AGENDA
TODAY ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB FOUR
FOUR SIX I DO WELL THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR AGAIN AND MEMBERS
THINK IF YOU'RE CAREFUL
ATTENTION- I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB FOUR
FOUR SIX AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY
ONLY SEVEN NEW POLITICAL
PARTIES OF QUALIFIED TO
PARTICIPATE IN CALIFORNIA
ELECTIONS WITH. SIX PARTIES
QUALIFYING THROUGH VOTER
REGISTRATION ONLY ONE
QUALIFYING THROUGH THE PETITION
PROCESS THEY FAILED THE STATE
QUALIFIED FOR SUBSEQUENT
ELECTIONS WHEN THEY FEEL THE
REGISTER ENOUGH VOTERS THIS
BILL WOULD REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
SIGNATURES NEEDED ON A PETITION
TO FORM A NEW POLITICAL PARTY
FROM 10% 23% PUTTING CALIFORNIA
IN LINE WITH THE VAST MAJORITY
OF OTHER STATES IN THE ASSEMBLY
LECTIONS COMMITTEE. RESEARCHING
THIS ISSUE WE FOUND THAT MOST
STATES ARE BETWEEN A TWO AND 5%
THIS BILL ALSO SEEKS TO FREE IT
NAMES A PRIOR UNSUCCESSFUL
POLITICAL MOVEMENTS BY ALLOWING
A NEW PROVIDER REGISTER WITH
THE NAME HAS BEEN ABANDONED FOR
MORE THAN TWO YEARS
REGISTRATIONS FROM PRIOR
EFFORTS WOULD ONLY COUNT
TOWARDS THE NEW EFFORT OF THE
LATTER BODY HAS A SIGNED
AFFIDAVIT AFFIDAVITS FROM THE
FORMER THAN THE LATTER BODY
REPRESENTS THE SAME PLATFORM
OTHERWISE PRIOR PRIOR PARTY
REGISTRATIONS WOULD NOT COUNT
THE NEW BODY ONCE ABANDONED BY
THE PRIOR EFFORTS. I LASTLY
THIS BILL FORMALIZE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE APPEALS
PROCESS WHEN APPLYING FOR A
PARTY NAME AND JUST DIDN'T- THE
TO END HERE I WANT TO THANK AT
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE- DOCTOR SHIRLEY WEBER
AND ALL OF HER STAFF ON WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS- WE ACTUALLY
TOOK SUBSTANTIAL SUBSTANTIAL-
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND- I DON'T
HAVE ANY OTHER- ANY WITNESSES
AND- IN SUPPORT I'M VERY HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE WILL.
FOLLOW OUR PROCESS AND ASK IF
THERE ARE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HERE IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
TO INDICATE SEEN NINE WILL GO
TO A REMOTE HEARING SPACE I SEE
NO ONE THERE WILL GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES. MODERATOR WOULD
YOU ASK. IF THE ANYONE WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AB FOUR FOUR
SIX TWO PLEASE- SO INDICATE. IF
YOU LIKE THIS ON OF THE FOUR
FOUR YOU MAY ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. POLITE NUMBER
THIRTY THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I KEPT GETTING CUT OFF I
WAS TRYING TO OPPOSE AB FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT BUT THEN I HAD TO
CALL BACK I THINK THE PHONES
ARE A CONSTANT CALIFORNIANS
SOME PROBLEMS IF YOU COULD NOTE
THE RECORD AB FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
MAYES I'M OPPOSED. AND THIS IS
SANDRA FROM ANY OF YOU WONDERED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
NEXT TO. WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
TO ASSIST ME IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOUR FOUR SIX- WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FOUR FOUR SIX. LOOKING HERE AND
ARE HEARING ROOM I SEE NO ONE
I'LL GO TO A REMOTE HEARINGS
FACING NO ONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR WOULD YOU
ASK ANYONE WHO WISH TO STEPS TO
FIND OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FOUR
FOUR SIX TO INDICATE. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB FOUR FOUR SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER SPEAKER WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY IN Q. IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME OKAY WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MEMBERS. SENATOR NEWMAN THANK
YOU MISTER SO ASSEMBLY RANGE AS
YOU NOTED ONE OF THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THE ADOPTION OF
THE- TOP TWO OPEN PRIMARY
pSYSTEM IS GUY IT DID NOT HAVE
WHAT. I THINK SOME OF THE-
FAMILIES HAD IN MIND WHICH WAS
TO GIVE THE SPACE AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO THIRD PARTIES
OR SMALLER PARTIES. RISER
PROJECT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
BUT I IF YOU WOULD CAN CAN YOU
GIVE ME JUST A LITTLE MORE
CONTEXT YOU KNOW AS TO. THE
IMPETUS IN ORIGINS OF THE BILL.
SURE I DON'T KNOW IT QUITE
FRANKLY WHERE- WHAT WHERE TO
START I'M PART OF THIS WAS-
LOTS OF CONVERSATIONS
INITIALLY- WITH THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE- I HAD BEEN.
THERE IS A POLITICAL PARTYOR
POLITICAL BODY SHOULD SAY- THAT
HAD REACHED OUT TO ME. I WITH
SOME DIFFERENT IDEAS AND SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE WAY THAT. A
THAT THE PROCESS THE PROCESS
WORKS AND ASKED IF I COULD
COULD COULD HELP OUT TO RESULT
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE. I'VE HAD SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM- AND AT
THE END OF ALL OF IT THIS IS
WHAT WE ENDED UP- COME COMING
UP WITH. A THERE ARE A COUPLE
OF DIFFERENT WAYS OF BEING ABLE
TO FORM. A POLITICAL PARTY
ACTUALLY HAS JUST TWO WAYS TO
BE ABLE TO FORM A POLITICAL
PARTY YOU CAN EITHER. GO OUT
AND- AND YOU COLLECT
REGISTRATIONS. OR YOU CAN GO
OUT AND GET FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY JUST SIGNED UP THIS TO
THIS BILL ACTUALLY. SAYS THAT
INSTEAD OF 10% THEY WOULD BE.
OF THREE PERCENT. I'VE LEARNED
A SENSE- A SENSE THAT
CONVERSATION- THAT- WHEN YOU DO
REGISTRATIONS- AFFECTED THERE
WAS A BILL THAT YOU ARE
CARRYING SENATOR- THAT ACTUALLY
DEALT WITH THAT VERY THING AND-
THAT WAS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
BECAUSE- YOU YOU HAVE. THIS
THIS ISSUE WHEN YOU'RE GOING
OUT ASKING PEOPLE TO SIGN UP TO
BE ABLE TO CHANGE THE
REGISTRATION- IT'S A FRAUD- CAN
BECOME BECOME VERY EASY. THE
OTHER THING IS IN REGARDS TO
THE IN THIS CONVERSATION THE
SECRETARY STATE REGARD. SEVEN
NAMES- IT SEEMED PRETTY CLEAR
THAT THE STATE. STATE NEEDED
SOMEHOW. NOT DEALING WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN A POLITICAL BODY
FORMS. BUT THEN DOESN'T DISBAND
THEY DON'T COLLECT ENOUGH
SIGNATURES ENOUGH
REGISTRATIONS. TO BE ABLE TO
BECOME A POLITICAL PARTY- AND
THEY NEEDED AN END DATE- OF FOR
THAT SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
IMPETUS OF. OF THAT LANGUAGE SO
ON THAT THE TENTO THREE- THAT
WAS THE ONE ON THE SECOND PART.
WAS DEALING WITH- WITH WITH
WITH THAT THE NAME CHANGE.
TICKETS ARE AT THE TIME. MAKES
SENSE BUT IT IS HIS DUTY TO
WHAT EXTENT IS THIS ADDRESS
THAT LARGER PROBLEM OF
PARTICIPATION ARE INFLUENCED BY
THE THIRD PARTY GROUPS IF AT
ALL I'VE BEEN PERHAPS IT DOES
WELL IF I'M THE WAY I TALK WAY
ALLOWS HEM TO GO FROM I MEAN
10% 23% OF THE POLITICAL BODY
FORMS THAT THEY ON'T HAVE TO
COLLECT AS MANY- AS A THAT'S-
THAT THAT WOULD BE BE GOOD AND
ALSO AGAIN CLARIFIES. WHAT WILL
BE OF SOMEBODY FILES A NAME-
THEN IT PROVIDES THE END DATE
FOR THAT OKAY THANK YOU THE
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. A
C. NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU FOR
YOUR WORK IN THIS AREA IT'S A
KIND OF A PERSON'S FACE SOME OF
IT IS. YOU WORKING WITHIN THE
PARAMETERS OF THE BALLOT
MEASURE THAT THAT CREATED THE
TOP TO. AND DOES PROVIDE SOME
LIMITATIONS THERE WHICH ARE.
IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO MODIFY
WITHOUT BRING IT BACK TO THE
VOTERS HAVE BEEN HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY
ANYTHING ON THE SAME CLOSING. I
RESPECT HER REQUEST AND I WILL
ALL RIGHT LOOKING FOR A MOTION
GLENN WILSHIRE FROM SENATOR
NEWMAN- THIS IS THAT TO PASS.
UP THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS AB
FOUR FOUR SIX OF THE CONSOLE
WOULD CALL THE ROLL. AB FOUR
FOUR SIX MOTION IS TO PASS THE
FIRST BE REFERRED COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER. AYE
GLAZER AYE NIELSEN. NIELSEN-
HERTZBERG. LEYVA FIVE RIVERSIDE
NEWMAN HI NEWMAN I. WE GET THAT
HAS THE VOTES TO GET APPLE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OF AND PERHAPS IN
MEMBERS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK TO
ITEM NUMBER THREE. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW. HELLO
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE WE
LOOK FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A THIRD GRADER AND
SENATORS FIRST OFF I TAKE SEVEN
MINUTES TO REDUCE THE PENALTY
PROPOSED. FROM THREE TO TWO
TIMES THE LAW UNLAWFUL EXPENDED
AMOUNT AND THANK THIS COMMITTEE
VERY MUCH FOR. YOUR PARTNERSHIP
IN ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES TO
ENSURE THAT- WE- PREVENT THIS
TYPE OF BLATANT AND EGREGIOUS
VIOLATIONS OF THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT WITH ME TODAY IS
LIVES IN THE CONDO LET'S THAT
HOUSE WITH THE FTC TO ALSO
TESTIFIED SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE
WILL GO TO YOUR LEAD WITNESS IN
SUPPORT LIVES IN A CONDO. LEAD
COUNSEL FOR THE FEC IS THE KIND
OF YOU ON THE LINE YOU CAN
BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY NOW. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS NINE CLINTON MCCONNELL
AND LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL FOR THE
FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION. IF THE FATHER AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. THE BILL
WOULD INCREASE THE MAXIMUM
PENALTY FOR UNLAWFUL PERSONAL
USE OF CAMPAIGN FUNDS AND THAT
USED RESULT IN A DIRECT
PERSONAL BENEFIT OF TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS MARK. UNDER
EXISTING LAW UNLAWFUL USE OF
CAMPAIGN FUNDS THAT RESULTS IN
A DIRECT PERSONAL BENEFIT OF
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS A MARKET
THAT THE TO A MAXIMUM PENALTY
OF FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS. I
DON'T DEMAND HOWEVER MAY NOT BE
AFFECTED IT IS A DETERRENT FOR
THE PENALTY THE AMOUNT OF THE
UNLAWFUL PERSONALLY IS A FUN
HI. ADDITIONALLY THE COMMISSION
CONSIDERS THESE KINDS OF
VIOLATIONS AT THE SOME A LOT.
UNDER THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT.
IS VIOLATIONS ERODE PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN PUBLIC OFFICIAL
THE CAMPAIGN PROCESS AND THE
POLITICAL PROCESS GENERALLY.
THE DIVERSION OF PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IS AMPLIFIED EVEN
FURTHER WHEN THE AMOUNT OF. THE
PERSONALLY USED IS ESPECIALLY
HIGH. THANK RATING MAXIMUM
PENALTY AGREE PRESS STEPPED.
FOR THE BILL BY ALIGNS THE
AMOUNT OF PENALTY BUT THE
DAMAGE CAUSED. HOPEFULLY THE TO
OTHERS IN THE FUTURE FROM ON
LAW USE CAMPAIGN FUNDS THEIR
OWN PERSONAL USE. THANK YOU FOR
THE CANADIAN. AND THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOCATED
LEADERSHIP AND COLLABORATION ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CONDO- WE DON'T HAVE ANY
FURTHER- LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES
SO WE'LL GO TO TESTIMONY HERE
IN THE CAPITAL. ANYONE HERE IN
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I DON'T
SEE ANYONE STANDING SO WE'LL GO
TO OUR PROMOTE HEARINGS FACE.
CENA NO ONE THERE WILL GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES. MODERATOR
WOULD YOU INVITE ANYONE WHO
WISHED TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN. PLEASE
SO INDICATING THAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM A LEAD SUPPORT WITH US WE
JUST HAVE TO PROVIDE YOUR NAME.
AND YOUR ASSOCIATION. OF ANY
AND YOUR POSITION OF SUPPORT.
IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND THERE'S NO ONE COMING UP IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
SO WE'LL GO TO THOSE WHO WANT
WHICH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
TO AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN WE
DON'T HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL LOOK HERE AND
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE WHERE OUR
HEARING IS TAKING PLACE I SEE
NO ONE. GO TO A REMOTE HEARING
SPACE SEE NO ONE WILL GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES MODERATE IF YOU
WOULD ASK THAT ANYBODY WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN A
PLEASE SO INDICATE. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND THERE IS NO ONE
QUEUING UP IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. SENATOR
NEWMAN. I BIG CENTER LOW TO GO
UP THAT'S ALL YEAH I'M GOOD
WITH THAT I WAS I WAS GOING
WITH IN COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
SENILE COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
AT ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK IN THIS AREA BUT
WE KNOW THAT THE THESE TYPES OF
ABUSES FORTUNATELY ARE VERY
RARE- BUT THEY ARE EGREGIOUS
WHEN THEY DO OCCUR I THINK YOUR
BILL IS TRY TO FIND THE RIGHT
BALANCE HI AND- APPROPRIATE
PENALTIES AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT TO GET TODAY WITH THE
AMENDMENT SAYS. AS YOU'VE
INDICATED YOU WOULD SUPPORT SO
WITH THAT I SEE CENTER LEYVA
MOVING THE BILL AS AMENDED AS A
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU FOR MUCH FOR HELPING
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE VERY
GOOD AND JUST TO CLARIFY THAT
THE AMENDMENT- QUOTE WITH A MAN
THAT REDUCES THE PENALTY
PROPOSED IN SECTION EIGHTY NINE
FIVE TWENTY ONE B. ONE FROM
THREE TIMES TO TWO TIMES. THE
AMOUNT OF THE UNLAWFUL
EXPENDITURE IF THE CONSOLE
WOULD CALL THE ROLL TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST A REFERRED.
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY SO THE MOST DEFERRED.
AMEND THE FIRST AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER AYE
GLAZER BY NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE
HERTZBERG. LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN HI. ALL
RIGHT THAT BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OF CONTRAPTION MEMBERS
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THAT
BRINGS US TO OUR LAST ITEM ON
OUR AGENDA ITEM NUMBER SIX.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN NINETY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN RIVAS.
SEE THAT YOU ARE HERE WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
TESTIMONY. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
THOROUGH EVALUATION OF THIS
BILL. AND FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON AMENDMENTS.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF FORTY FIVE
STATE. THAT ALLOWS ITS GOVERNOR
TO APPOINT A PERSON TO FILL A
VACANCY IN THE U. S. SENATE.
WHEN A VACANCY OCCURS. EARLY IN
A SIX YEAR SENATE TERM THAT
APPOINTEE SERVICE UNTIL AN
ELECTION IS HELD. TO SELECT THE
PERSON WHO SERVES THE REMAINDER
OF THE TERM. EARLIER THIS YEAR.
THEN SENATOR KAMILLA HARRIS
RESIGNED HER U. S. SENATE SEAT
IN ADVANCE OF BEING INAUGURATED
AS VICE PRESIDENT. THAT
RESIGNATION CREATED A VACANCY
IN CALIFORNIA'S REPRESENTATION
IN THE U. S. SENATE FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THIRTY YEARS AND
TRIGGERED A RE EXAMINATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S LAWS. FOR FILLING
SUCH VACANCIES SINCE THE LAST
VACANCY OCCURRED IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE TO APPELLATE COURTS
ISSUE DECISIONS THAT RAISE
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
CALIFORNIA'S. U. S. SENATE
VACANCY PROCEDURES ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE SEVENTEENTH
AMENDMENT TO THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION. IN PARTICULAR IT
IS UNCLEAR WHETHER STATE LAW
ALLOWING AN APPOINTEE TO HOLD
OFFICE FOR THE REMAINDER. OF
THE SENATE TERM UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES COMPLIES WITH THE
SEVENTEENTH AMENDMENT. AB
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE WILL
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA LAW IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE SEVENTEENTH
AMENDMENT TO THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION BY PROVIDING FOR
AN ELECTION TO BE HELD. FOR THE
VACANCY AND CALIFORNIA'S
REPRESENTATION IN THE U. S.
SENATE EVEN IF THE VACANCY
OCCURS DURING THE LAST TWO
YEARS OF THE U. S. SENATE TERM.
IN ORDER TO AVOID THE COSTS AND
DISRUPTIONS OF STANDALONE
STATEWIDE SPECIAL ELECTIONS. AB
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE REQUIRES
U. S. SENATE VACANCY ELECTIONS
TO BE CONSOLIDATED. WITH
REGULARLY SCHEDULED STATEWIDE
ELECTIONS. IF THE TIMING OF THE
VACANCY DOES NOT ALLOW U. S.
SENATE VACANCY ELECTION TO BE
CONSOLIDATED. WITH THE LAST.
STATEWIDE PRIMARY AND GENERAL
ELECTION HELD DURING THAT TERM.
AB FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE
ESTABLISHES A PROCEDURE FOR THE
GOVERNOR TO SCHEDULE A SPECIAL
PRIMARY AND GENERAL. ELECTION
FOR THE REMAINDER OF THE TERM
IF IT IS PRACTICAL TO DO SO. L.
A. COUNTY IS CURRENTLY PILOTING
A PROJECT USING AN ALTERNATE
BALLOT ORDER WHERE LOCAL
OFFICES APPEAR ON THE BALLOT
BEFORE STATE AND FEDERAL OFFICE.
IT'S UNCLEAR HOW THIS WOULD
IMPACT PARTICIPATION WHEN A
SPECIAL VACANCY ELECTION AND
REELECTION WOULD APPEAR ON THE
SAME BALLOT BUT IN DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS. AB FOURTEEN NINETY
FIVE WILL ENSURE THAT WHEN A
SPECIAL VACANCY ELECTION AND A
REGULAR ELECTION FOR THE SAME
LEGISLATIVE OR CONGRESSIONAL
SEAT APPEAR ON THE SAME BALLOT
THAT VOTERS. WILL BE WILL BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY AND UNDERSTAND
THIS BY PLACING THE TWO
ELECTIONS AT THE FRONT OF THE
BALLOT WITH CLEARLY CLEARLY
MARKED HADER'S. TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
I HAVE MELISSA ROMERO FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN WILL
GO TO YOUR LEAD WITNESS IN
SUPPORT MISTER AMERO YOU'RE ON
THE PHONE LINES YOU'RE LOOKING
TO BEGIN. GOOD MORNING IT
MELISSA ROMERO THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE. NOT ONLY IS THIS
AN IMPORTANT OPEN A FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA LINE YOU'VE GOT TO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION. SO OFTEN SURE
THAT WHENEVER THERE IS A
VACANCY IN THE U. S. SENATE.
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
DEMOCRACY AND AVOID CONFLICT
THEN FOUND IN THE U. S. SENATE.
AND REPRESENTATION BUT
CALIFORNIANS IN THE SENATE THE
CRITICAL DECISION THAT ALL
VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA TEACHER
PAKISTAN ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING
THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA STILL
ONLY HAS CHIU SENATORS
REPRESENTING OUR STATE IN THE
LAST MINUTE BUT BY OUR ENORMOUS
ABILITY COMPARED TO MUCH
SMALLER STATE YOU ALSO. HAVE
MINUTES. AND THE U. S. SENATE
IS NOT MUCH MORE IMPORTANT FOR
EACH OF THE VOTER. COULD
PRIORITIZE MY- ACCESS. TO
PATIENT COULD A LACK. BY NEARLY.
ONE HAVE MUCH HIGHER
PARTICIPATION RATE AND
INCLUDING A LOT AT BUT IT'S
MUCH MORE OF A- OF THE STATE
POPULAR. THANK WIDE SPECIAL
ELECTION. PROTECT WHEN IT TO
AGE AND RACIAL RIGHT. I WOULD.
A LOT COULD BE HELD FILL THEIR-
OF THE U. S. SENATE. MAKING
CURRENT AND PROVIDE NETWORK. IN
THE CASE IT'S NOT TO HOLD THE-
BEFORE THAT TO AND- BELIEVE WE
CAN FIVE IN. HOW DO NOT GO OUT
PERFECTLY. IN THE U. S.
CALIFORNIA INCOME WITH THE S.
CONSTITUTION. AND KNOCKING THE
VOTER. BY HOLDING VACANCY. I
THINK TIME OF REGULAR SCHEDULED
STATEWIDE PRIMARY AND ELECTIONS
WHENEVER POSSIBLE. THERE
DIRECTION AT THE STATE TIME AS
REGULAR CADILLAC. ENSURE THAT
THERE'S AMPLE UP BUT TO BE
EDUCATED ON THEIR OPTIONS
PROMOTING WHAT ABOUT THE CANADA.
AND THE CANDIDATES LEAD WITH
THE ELECTRIC AND GOLLY REASON.
AB FORTY FIVE ON THE TO
COMMITTEE I. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK VERY MUCH AND ROMERO.
CLEAR TEST I DON'T THE OTHER
THE WITNESSES- AND SUPPORTS ALL
OF TO THOSE WHO TO TEST HERE
THE CAP. HEARING ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE I DON'T SEE
ANYONE STANDING WILL GO TO OUR-
HEARING SPACE. NO ONE THERE ARE
GO TO A PHONE LINE MONTEREY.
WOULD YOU ASK THE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO. SPEAK IN SOME OF AB
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE TO PLEASE
SO INDICATE. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT A BI FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
THERE IS NO ONE SHOWING UP IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
VERY GOOD WILL GO TO THOSE WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO AB FOURTEEN NINETY FIVES OR
ANYONE HERE IN THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE OUR ROOM HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. C. NINE WILL GO TO A
REMOTE HEARING SPACE. C. NINE
WILL GO TO OUR PHONE LINES
MODERATOR YOU ASK THOSE WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO AB FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE TO
PLEASE INDICATE. LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AB FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE IS NO ONE IN Q. IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME I WANT
TO GIVE IT ONE LAST CHANCE-
OPERATOR IF WOULD YOU DO IT ONE
ONE LAST CALL TO SEE IF ANYONE
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO. A. B. FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE. ALL RIGHT IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK ON AB FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
THERE IS NO ONE TO AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU THANK
YOUR MODERATOR FOR ALL YOUR
GOOD WORK WITH US TODAY. SO
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK
YOU MISTER SERVICE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RISKY TO SEE YOU. KNOW I
DO HAVE A QUESTION AS THE
COMMISSION ELSE'S NOTES THERE
THERE THERE ARE. IN QUESTION
ABOUT VOTER CONFUSION-
SPECIFICALLY WHERE YOU'RE
HAVING TO KERN ALEXION'S TO
FILL. THE REMAINDER THE GERMAN
AND ALSO THE IT THE SAME TIME
THE ELECTION FOR THE- FOR THE
PRIMARY GUESTS- FOR WHAT WOULD
BE THE REGULAR TERMS TO WHICH
WE HAVE SOME EXPERIENCE WITH
THAT RECENTLY THERE WAS A- IT
WAS IN THE SENATE ELECTION FOR.
US SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY TWO-
WHERE EXACTLY THIS SCENARIO
TOOK PLACE AND IT WAS CLEAR.
THAT THE VOTERS WERE. A GOOD
ASPECT. THAT CHECKED RECORD SIR
THE IT WAS CLEAR TO ME FROM THE
RESULT THE THAT THE VOTERS.
EITHER WERE CONFUSED MANAGING.
OF WILL BE ONE PERSON GOT
ELECTED FOR A VERY SHORT TERM
OF SOMETHING LIKE TWO MONTHS.
AND AT THE SAME TIME THAT SAME
PERSON DID NOT QUALIFY- TO MOVE
THROUGH. INTO THE GENERAL
THOUGHT HAVING FAILED- IN THE
CURRENT PRIMARY SO. WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT- BECAUSE
DID YOU KNOW DID IT IS
CONFUSING AND YOU MIGHT WIND UP
WITH. SOMETHING LIKE THE
OPPOSITE OF THE INTENDED RESULT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION
SENATOR. I WAS IN THAT SAME
SITUATION AND MY ELECTION I WAS
ON THE BALLOT TWICE- HI. I RAN
TO FILL AN UNEXPIRED TERM. FROM
MY PREDECESSOR THAT RESIGNED-
AND YOU KNOW IT WAS A LOT OF
WORK TO GET PEOPLE TO VOTE.
TWICE AND YOU KNOW I
UNFORTUNATELY WAS SUCCESSFUL
YOU MENTIONED THE CASE OF
SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY TO WEAR.
TWO DIFFERENT CANDIDATES ONE
ONE THE SPECIAL ONE ONE THE- OF
THE REGULAR ELECTION. I THINK.
IF WE WORK TOWARDS IT YOU KNOW
IT I THINK IT'S UP TO EACH
CANDIDATE TO WORK. TOWARD
ELIMINATING THAT CONFUSION- BUT
IN THIS CASE- WE NEED TO DO
THIS BECAUSE IT BECAUSE OF
THAT- YOU KNOW WE WANT. THE
SPECIAL AND THE REGULAR TO BE
ON THE SAME BALLOT WE COULD END
UP. WITH THE REMAINDER OF AN
EGG UNEXPIRED TERM ON FILLED.
UNTIL YOU KNOW FROM BETWEEN
NOVEMBER AND JANUARY- WHILE I
AGREE WITH YOU THAT IT. IT CAN
CONFUSE VOTERS. WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA IS
REPRESENTED. IN THE U. S.
SENATE. EVEN FOR THAT SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME. AND WE DON'T
WANT ANYTHING. TO BE VAGUE. OR
FOR US NOT TO LIKE I SAID NOT
TO HAVE. A REPRESENTATIVE. AT
THE U. S. SENATE. THE AVERAGE I
GUESS I GUESS YOU'RE OF THE DAY
THE TRAY OFF VERY VERSES- YOU
KNOW HAVING MATURITY OF
SOMEBODY IN THAT OFFICE- DOUG I
WOULD. YOU KNOW URGING THERE'S
NOT A LOT OF. OPPORTUNITIES AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD BUT
IT'S PROBABLY WORTH
CONSIDERING- IF THERE ARE WAYS
TO ADDRESS THEM SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS- ASSEMBLY
WOMAN THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
IN LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA AND
PARTICULAR. I KNOW WHAT KIND OF.
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT OF A LATE
REVIEW BY A LOT OF THOUGHTFUL
PEOPLE TO KIND OF BRING THIS
BILL TO WHERE IT IS TODAY THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH OUR STAFF
ON IT AS WELL I THINK THAT
SENATOR NEWMAN DOES RAISE THE
ISSUE WITH THE DAY THAT I KNOW
YOU RECOGNIZE AS WELL AND- AND
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
LOOK FOR REMEDIES TO TRY TO
DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE OF VOTER
CONFUSION I KNOW YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT. WOULD
ASK THE TO- CONTINUE THAT WORK
WITH US IS- AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD BUT HAPPY TO SUPPORT
TODAY. WITH THAT SENATOR LEYVA
HAS MOVED THIS BILL THIS IS A-
DO PASSED BUT REFER TO THE-
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU I WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN
MISTER CHAIR- FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON THIS FILM AND ESPECIALLY
TO EUROPE COMMITTEE- FOR
WORKING- WITH MY TEAM. AND
OTHERS. ON THIS IMPORTANT BELL-
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITH THAT IF THE CONSOLE WILL
CALL THE ROLL. AB FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG AYE LEYVA. LIVER HI
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT HUMAN HI. THAT
BILL IS OUT IS AT FIVE ZERO
FIVE ZERO TRAFFIC THANK YOU SO
MUCH IS ON THE WOMAN WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
MEASURES THAT WE LEFT ON CALL.
FOR THOSE OF MEMBERS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE HEARING
FROM THE START YOU'RE FREE TO
GO AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION- CONSOLE LET'S
BEGIN WITH THE ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB THIRTY SEVEN BY SELLING
MEMBER BERMAN. AB THIRTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE IS TO
ONE WITH THE TERRIBLE- AND THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO- I.
HERTZBERG AYE LEYVA. LEYVA I.
RIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT FOR THE
ONE WITH NEXT I'VE NEVER AB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN SOLD CALL THE
ROLL. AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE IS
THREE ZERO WITH THE CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HIGH LEYVA. LEYVA I.
THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE ZERO. IS
THAT CORRECT CONSULTORA TOP
FIVE ZERO MOVED ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG BY. ALL
RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT FIVE
ZERO. MOVED THE NEXT ITEM
NUMBER FOR A BI FOR TWENTY
EIGHT BY MAYES. AB FOUR TO
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO VOTE IS TO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING IDENTIFIES HER
VOTING NO. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE. HAD BILLS OUT THREE TO.
MOVE NEXT ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
FOUR FOUR SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAYES. AB FOUR FOUR SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS VOTE IS THREE
ONE WITH A TEAR VOTING I AM THE
VICE FOR VOTING NO. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG GUY. THAT DEALS OUT
FOR ONE. AND WE COMPLETED. ITEM
NUMBER SIX OKAY. ARE THAT
COMPLETES OUR WORK OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS
AND CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS.
IF YOU WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
WHO DID PARTICIPATE TODAY
CERTAINLY TO OUR WONDERFUL
COMMITTEE STAFF. IF YOU WERE
NOT BLE TO TESTIFY YOU CAN
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
COMMITTEE- OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT. AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THAT CONCLUDES
OUR WORK. WHEN I WISH EVERYONE
A GOOD DAY THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON ELECTIONS A CONSTITUTIONAL.
AMENDMENTS IS OFFICIALLY
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.